make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and
yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is rob and i'm
gonna be honest with you guys i had no
idea that you guys would be that
interested
in the the enter the phoenix story from
jason aaron i didn't know you guys were
going to dig it that much
if i'm being honest i thought it was
going to perform kind of bad and i was
like i mean i don't really care like i
just want to cover the story but it
performed great
and you guys loved it which is awesome
because this one's better so uh here's
the thing
right like in that first video captain
america became the phoenix that's cool
in this one i was kind of it was tough
to figure out what title
i was going to use so i decided to use
both black panther and hyperion
get the phoenix force in this story it's
kind of nuts right it's pretty crazy
here uh so
initially this kind of opens up with
black panther now here's a cool thing to
understand about this right
i love chadwick boseman as black panther
in the marvel cinematic universe
unfortunately
he passed before we really got to see
the full fruition of his character black
panther in the comics is
nuts he's amazing i i think okay so
here's the thing a lot of people ask me
this what's the best black panther story
ever the best black panther story ever
of all time really comes down to three
writers right christopher priest
reginald hudlund and uh jonathan hickman
oh my god if you guys never saw if you
guys ever read jonathan hickman's
avengers new avengers check out the
playlist down in the description right
it's just it's a ridiculously good
it's so amazing it's such a ridiculously
good story anyway so this basically
opens up with black panther kind of
amusing to himself now
while i will say that jason aaron of
course doesn't handle black panther as
well as jonathan hickman did he still
does it exceedingly well right so one of
the things that makes t'challa such a
formidable guy
is one like the abilities he has from
the panther god but two his intelligence
and his ability to be dispassionate in a
situation right and so he kind of talks
about this this whole concept that's
going on he kind of says that like steve
rogers you know punches the scenery
impatiently because all he really knows
how to do is fight
thor laughs to hide his brooding carol
danvers broods to hide her laughter
tony armors his fragile ego one
egotistical word at a time
like we all have our routines and that's
the cool thing here right
it's one of the things about black
panther when he originally joined the
avengers in marvel comics
he did it to spy on the team to make
sure they were never going to be a
credible threat to wakanda is one of the
coolest revelations that came out of
came out of marvel at the time uh back
in the the 70s really
well it wasn't really until the 70s that
you kind of found out what was going on
but it was cool right the 70s 80s that
kind of a thing and so uh he kind of
says like you know in the moment before
a battle
i seek to empty myself of all but the
essential
one must fight with great emotion but
one must not fight emotionally and that
kind of stuff right there like that
philosophy
is really what makes black panther so
incredibly cool right so as he's kind of
here
and sort of meditating suddenly he's set
upon by the arrival of the man thing now
the man thing is a character you almost
never hear about i wouldn't be surprised
if you saw some reference to the man
thing and doctor strange multiverse of
madness right the reason why is because
the man thing guards the nexus of all
realities in the florida everglades and
you can't simply just go
through the nexus you have to basically
pass the man thing who's a test
and the idea is that those individuals
who know fear burn at the touch of the
man thing
and that's why you see this kind of
engagement here where even even uh
black panther says that right like those
who know fear burn at the touch of the
man thing so literally
he touches black panther in that moment
when he just lays a finger on him if
black panther was scared
he would have died just like that like
would have just burst into flames and
died such as it is
black panther is not a freedom and so
it's the coolest thing in the world to
see him survive this whole thing right
see him survivors at that point it just
turns into a knock-down dragon fight now
the disappointing thing about this is
that while black panther is a great
character and him being imbued with the
power of the phoenix
is super impressive in the end it's
momentary i mean i will say
black panther with the phoenix force
looks amazing like
it looks amazing i love the way this
looks and i kind of want to see him stay
like this forever because it just it
looks like it looks
it looks like the coolest thing ever
right like it's awesome but basically
what i'm saying right
he just it looks it just looks awesome
but the reality is
jason aaron kind of makes this so fast
because it's designed to show
what t'challa is capable of when he
attains such a high level of power and
we've seen him do that before right when
t'challa had
when he got the infinity gauntlet when
black panther had the infinity gauntlet
during jonathan hickman's secret wars
dude it was nuts right he literally led
an army of the dead against uh against
god king doom against emperor doom and
hen had like no fear his conviction his
resolve was absolute
and it was one of the coolest things
right so essentially he just kind of
punches a hole to the man thing pummels
them and then burns him right now the
reality is the man thing will regrow in
a lot of ways he's kind of marvel's
version of swamp thing so he'll always
regrow he'll always end up coming back
and then black panther basically shows
back up to the white hot room now there
is a little bit of discussion here among
the various people who were in this spot
who kind of talk about what's going on
and where where they're at and what's
happening wolverine answers it pretty
quickly and basically saying that
they're in the white hot room they're
basically in a place that's reserved for
those individuals who have the power to
possess the phoenix force
but it also makes sense that because the
phoenix is using them for a tournament
the phoenix would use it as a way
station right just kind of use it as a
place to hold them
and they're effectively cut off from
everything right so like black panther
for example cannot commune with the
panther got with the the black panthers
of the past he can't even talk to us on
panther god right he's kind of shut off
from all these different places but
suddenly there's people here that we
weren't really aware of before right
like you've got shauna who's the the
queen of the savage land you've got the
orb i don't even know why he's here but
ultimately
you have name of the submariner who kind
of goads and sort of boasts and kind of
says look like you know i don't know
like what's you know i know what's going
on but like at the end of the day like i
don't really care about any of these
people's bickering like just tell me who
i need to fight and that'll be it now
he's kind of
trying to goad people into a conflict so
we can kind of weed individuals out
one-on-one now ultimately she-hulk is
the one who takes the bait but she's
immediately attacked and kind of set
back by the phoenix and it's like no
right like you will fight who i want you
to fight and so the next person selected
in this tournament is luke cage now luke
cage with the the phoenix force yeah it
kind of looks okay right it's not the
greatest thing in the history of the
world he fights american eagle who's
basically just a guy from the navajo
nation so it's almost kind of like john
proud star to a degree it's pretty
interesting you've got shauna you know
the the she devil basically the leader
of the savage land for those of you guys
who don't know what that is the savage
land is a place in antarctica
where you basically have like dinosaurs
and stuff like that and different people
have used it as a base of operations but
it's like prehis like
the earth and prehistoric times which is
confined to that area of the antarctica
now the reason why it exists is because
of the beyonders who are kind of
conducting a small scale experiment and
essentially
doing an almost noah's ark kind of
situation which is where they had a race
travel around the world and then
basically round up all these different
flora and fauna and then drop them off
in the antarctic and leave them there uh
and then it kind of allows you know
people to use it for their own ends and
there's all kinds of like civilizations
and societies there but at the end of
the day they're fighting on the blue
area of the moon which is a portion of
the moon that has
oxygen of course she's not gonna fight
uh she's not gonna fight luna uh lunella
lafayette right the moon girl she's
gonna fight like devil dinosaur devil
dinosaur the phoenix force
looks terrifying it looks horrifying i
would never want to fight a t-rex with a
phoenix force
it looks horrifying but you kind of see
these things right you know in in
subterranea basically uh
the realm of a combination of the
deviants and the molement you've
basically got jane foster facing off
against the orbs
so not a whole lot going on here one of
the cool moments that takes place is at
wondergore mountain right which is
technically the home of the high
evolutionary and you've got hyperion
who's imbued with the power of the
phoenix now the reality here is of all
the people in this group the most
powerful just
under ordinary circumstances is hyperion
he's the closest that marvel has to
superman and marvel comics he's like the
definitive superman analog
in marvel comics but uh but yeah him
with the phoenix force looks cool
so having his power bolstered by that of
the phoenix he dwarfs everybody here
in all honesty it's the one part of the
story that i don't like
in terms of the way that jason aaron
handled it and the sense that hyperion
with all this power
is just kind of like man like you know i
can feel my fingers like reaching into
infinity right like i've got cosmic
awareness now right he basically knows
everything going on
across the universe and then becomes
afraid of it because in his mind it's
like oh my god like i'm gonna go crazy
i'm gonna use this power for evil
different things like that
it kind of has this existential crisis
and then just gives up right and then
you get to see shang chi with the
phoenix force which looks
really cool but he just gives up and
it's probably the weakest moment it's
like really jason aaron you gave you
gave the phoenix force to
essentially superman and you have him
give up like come on but at the same
time i also kind of understand because
this guy could have just overpowered and
destroyed
everybody right like everybody would
have just been completely and totally
obliterated and so there's really not a
whole lot you can do there now the next
thing that we get is actually in
greenwich village where dr
strange exists at least in doctor
strange's kitchen where you have howard
the duck facing off against the red
widow now the red widow is a new
creation
by by jason aaron right she appeared in
uh in avengers issue number 10. we know
that she is not yelena bova
uh just because of the fact that yolanda
bova appeared way back in the day she's
been around for a long long time in
marvel comics so you know she's not
really new here i mean she appeared back
in an inhuman story in 2005. so you know
elena is not a new character as far as
red widow goes she never talks or where
else obviously a chick right she's got
boobs but like she never talks uh only
women are ever trained to become widows
anyway but like she never talks we never
hear anything from her we have no
indication of who this chick
is right so it's a wholly different
beast of course she beats howard the
duck to death
right destroys howard the duck and
that's kind of it but following that you
have kind of the the phoenix force
letting off this psychic projection and
then meeting with black panther now it
is to a degree the phoenix but it almost
seems like it's kind of not in the sense
that this being acts autonomously and
refers to the phoenix as like she and
her as an other entity beyond herself so
it's
a little interesting to see it kind of
related to in that way but it's really
cool because at the end of the day
this this harbinger more or less says
like like tells black panther the
phoenix wants you right like you're the
person the phoenix wants and ultimately
black panther has like the coolest
moment here right
only t'challa would look at the emissary
of a multiversal force of energy that
represents the sum total
of all life that has ever currently does
and will ever exist that could burn
universes to ash
and respond to a statement from this
emissary in saying
i will make you an offer that if you
allow me like if you become a host of
the phoenix then
we can burn the name of wakanda in the
skies but if you turn it down
then like then we'll destroy wakanda
only t'challa would respond to that and
saying actually i'll make you an offer
right either you can leave here
or i can destroy you right i will spare
your life if you go away and then like
only t'challa would do that
only t'challa would look at like a
multiversal force of energy and be like
i will spare your life if you leave like
it's the most baller thing ever right
like that is a man without fear
that is a fearless dude but like
literally black panther that's that's
the thing man like black panther is cool
like people love black panther because
of chadwick boseman's
portrayal in the mcu but like you don't
know the half of how
awesome black panther is in marvel
comics right he's just he is
so cool right like but one of the
coolest things about him is his loyalty
as king to wakanda
make no mistake no matter what you see
black panther do as like
as like an avenger or if he's fighting
alongside the x-men or when he took the
role of daredevil and became like black
panther the man without fear
it doesn't matter if black panther has
to make the choice between saving
wakanda and letting the world die he'll
let the world die
but he'll let the world burn before he
lets anything happen to wakanda right
he'll even turn against the world and
destroy it if he has to
in order to save his people his his
loyalty to his citizens is
that strong it's just he's he's god he's
such an amazing character i love the
character of black panther and so
whether it's because of the fact that he
was mouthing off to the phoenix or
because of the fact that the next round
has started regardless what the reason
was
black panther is basically teleported
back to the florida everglades where he
faces off against
nighthawk now here's the thing about
nighthawk and i'm not sure
i'm really on board with this nighthawk
is kyle richman who's an interesting
character i'll be honest with you guys i
think the biggest moment nighthawk ever
had is when he was basically shanghaied
and uh into the squadron sinister by roy
thomas and
salvador back in 1969 right like that
whole squadron sinister thing he's been
around ever since but he's just besides
that he's
never been a character that i cared
about i'm sure there are some super
hardcore nighthawk fans who love his
character will be like no rob
that's wrong he had all these amazing
amazing moments and if he did feel free
to listen down in the comments right i'm
not gonna hold it against you i mean
some of them might be really cool but he
was never really an interesting
character to me what i'm a little on the
fence about is that the last time we saw
him was in squadron supreme volume
4. and basically it turned out that like
he'd been impersonated by a scroll um i
don't really know what they're doing
with that but at the moment jason aaron
almost kind of seems to be trying to
create
an almost black panther and neymar the
submariner grudge
between black panther and nighthawk i
know black panther i know nighthawk was
like part of the defenders and there's
some history there things like that but
the reality is the the various grudges
and
the issues that black panther and and uh
nighthawk had never came anywhere close
to being as cool as the grudge between
like black panther and neymar right but
at the end of the day
essentially kyle richmond has kind of
been working to like infiltrate and
influence wakanda and there's kind of a
lot going on there with regards to
what's what's been happening in the
black panther stories
uh by tadahasi coates and yeah his name
escapes from the guy who took over after
but at the moment the fight just kind of
comes down to them right now again
it's just another stage in this conflict
of who's going to be the last person
standing
that gets to wield the phoenix force and
so again the last little battle that we
get to switch to is one between maya
lopez and
neymar the submariner but maya lopez is
basically a character who goes by the
name of ekko right she appeared back in
daredevil
in uh 1999 with uh with david mack i
think was the one that wrote it and then
reappeared again
in brian michael bendis uh new avengers
which was great but maya lopez basically
has the ability to mirror the power a
mirror the fighting style of anybody she
sees
by just watching it right like for
example during the old
1999 daredevil story she actually saw a
fight between daredevil and bullseye and
then was able to like
copy the moves of both and then went to
go fight daredevil and actually
overpowered him right so like it was
really cool to see that happen she's
like a female version of taskmaster
more or less except tony masters can do
what he do partly because of he was
him being born with that power and also
because his power was bolstered right by
like a formula that he that he took
so uh there were there's some things
that kind of enhanced him and make him
you know a little more capable
uh just beyond what he was normally able
to do but maya lopez is cool
right and so maya lopez kind of being
imbued with this power of the phoenix
going by the name echo
why all standards of measurement it
looks like she'll probably end up being
the winner just because of the caveat of
being able to duplicate the powers
or the the fighting style of anybody she
sees ultimately though she's going
against neymar the submariner and name
of the submariner does not hold back he
looks amazing as the phoenix but neymar
man here's the thing man
people sleep on namor sometimes that's
the thing like people people have this
tendency to underestimate neymar like
they're like he's got wings on his feet
and like he was the first mutant in the
in like marvel comics you know the first
person to ever be published as a mutant
marvel comics
rahu right he's just he he lives in the
water and then who lives in a pineapple
under the sea
name more submariner like that's people
just kind of sleep on him and that's
basically it but neymar
namor is pretty legit right he's pretty
awesome so uh with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
if you are new here to comments explain
make sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
peace
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
it
[Music]
you